Liz:
[Music] It would have
been bad if I didn't have it. I'm sorry, Liz and I. I'm
meeting here with the daughter of Count Achille, who isn't Elizabeth, and I'm going to have a book club,
or maybe a strategy meeting, or what should I say,
Hoku-sama.  So, I'm actually
going to go back
home for a while starting next week. I heard that a lot of monsters have been seen in the Ho family's territory lately. It's
not an urgent matter. I see my parents' faces regularly.  It
also means fulfilling my duty as a son to see you.However,
my parents' house is far away from Oto,
which means I won't be able to see you for a while, so I
was looking for you because I wanted to see your face before I delivered.  I
'm sorry, Lis, but I accidentally
remembered what I had to do.
Liz, I wonder if you
could ask Mr. Hoku, who is there, to be your partner for the strategy meeting. Well
then, take it easy,
Liz.